[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JASON KU: Good
morning, everybody.
STUDENT: Morning--
JASON KU: My name's Jason Ku.
I'm going to be teaching
this class in Introduction
to Algorithms with two
other instructors here--
faculty in the department--
Eric Demaine and Justin Solomon.
They're excellent
people, and so they
will be working on teaching
this class with me.
I will be teaching
the first lecture,
and we'll have
each of them teach
one of the next two lectures,
and then we'll go from there.
This is Intro to Algorithms.
OK, so we're going to start
talking about this course
content now.
What is this course about?
It's about algorithms--
introduction to algorithms.
Really what the
course is about is
teaching you to solve
computational problems.
But it's more than that.
It's not just about
teaching you to solve
computational problems.
Goal 1-- solve
But it's more than that.
It's also about communicating
those solutions to others
and being able to communicate
that your way of solving
the problem is
correct and efficient.
So it's about two more things--
prove correctness,
argue efficiency,
and in general, it's
about communication--
I can't spell, by the way--
communication of these ideas.
And you'll find that, over
the course of this class,
you'll be doing a lot
more writing than you do
in a lot of your other courses.
It really should maybe
be a CI kind of class,
because you'll be doing a
lot more writing than you
will be coding, for sure.
Of course, solving the
computational problem
is important, but
really, the thing
that you're getting out of this
class and other theory classes
that you're not getting in
other classes in this department
is that we really
concentrate on being
able to prove that the
things you're doing
are correct and better
than other things,
and being able to communicate
those ideas to others, and not
just to a computer--
to other people, convince
them that it's correct.
OK, so that's what
this class is about.
So what do I mean when I say
solve a computational problem?
What is a problem?
What is an algorithm?
People make fun of me because
I start with this question,
but anyone want to
answer that question?
No?
What's a problem,
computationally?
No?
OK, so it's not such
a stupid question.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Something
you want to compute--
OK, yes, that's true.
Right.
But a little bit more
abstractly, what I'm going to
think of a computational
problem being--
and this is where
your prerequisite
in discrete mathematics
should come in--
a problem is-- you've
got a set of inputs.
Maybe I have one, two, three,
four, five possible inputs
I could have to my algorithm.
Then I have a space of outputs.
I don't know.
Maybe I have more of
them than I do inputs,
but these are the possible
outputs to my problem.
And what a problem is
is a binary relation
between these
inputs and outputs.
Essentially, for each input, I
specify which of these outputs
is correct.
It doesn't necessarily
have to be one.
If I say, give me the index in
an array containing the value
5, there could be multiple
5's in that array,
and so any of those
indices would be correct.
So maybe this guy maps to that
output, and maybe this guy maps
to--
I don't know-- two
or three outputs.
This input goes to one, two--
I don't know.
There's some kind
of mapping here.
These edges represent
a binary relation,
and it's kind of a
graph, a bipartite graph
between these
inputs and outputs.
And these are specifying
which of these outputs
are correct for these inputs.
That's really the
formal definition
of what a problem is.
Now, generally, if
I have a problem--
a computational
problem, I'm not going
to specify the problem to you
by saying, OK, for input 1,
the correct answer is
0, and for input 2,
the correct answer's 3,
and so on and so forth.
That would take forever, right?
Usually what we do
when defining a problem
is specify some kind of
predicate, saying that,
oh, we can check--
if I give you an
input and an output,
I can check whether that
output is correct or not.
That's usually how we
define a problem is,
if I am checking for whether
this index contains a 5,
I can just go to that array,
look at index 5, and--
or the index you gave me,
and see if it equals 5.
So usually, we're putting
it in terms of predicates
because, in general,
we don't really
want to talk about small
instances of problems.
So let's say I had
the problem of,
among the students in this
classroom, do any pair of you
have the same birthday?
All right, well, probably, if
there's more than 365 of you,
the answer is yes.
Right?
By what?
Pigeonhole
principle-- two of you
must have the same birthday.
So let's generalize it
a little bit, say that--
I don't know--
I need a bigger space of
birthdays for this question
to be interesting.
Maybe I tack on the year.
Maybe I tack on the
hour that you were born.
And that's a bigger
space of inputs,
and I wouldn't necessarily
expect that two of you
would be born in the
same year on the same day
in the same hour.
That would be a
little less likely.
In fact, as long as that
space is larger than something
like the square of the
number of you, then
I'm less likely than even
to have a pair of you.
That's a birthday problem
you may have seen in 042,
potentially.
But in general, I don't--
I'm not going to mess with
probability so much here.
I want a deterministic
algorithm, right away
of checking whether two of
you have the same birth time,
let's say.
OK, so in general,
in this class,
we're not going to
concentrate on inputs such as,
is there a pair of
you in this class
that have the same birthday?
That's kind of boring.
I could do a lot of
different things,
but what we do in
this class-- this
is for a fixed classroom of you.
I want to make algorithms that
are general to any classroom--
to go to your recitation.
I want an algorithm that will
apply to your recitation.
I want an algorithm that not
only applies to this classroom,
but also the machine
learning class before you.
I want an algorithm
that can change its--
it can accept an
arbitrarily sized input.
Here we have a class of
maybe 300, 400 students,
but I want my algorithm to
work for a billion students.
Maybe I'm trying
to check if there's
a match of something in
the Facebook database
or something like that.
So in general, we are looking
for general problems that
have arbitrarily sized inputs.
So these inputs could
grow very large,
but we want kind of a
fixed size algorithm
to solve those problems.
So what is an algorithm, then?
I really can't spell--
told you.
I didn't lie to you.
So an algorithm is a little
different than a problem.
A problem specification--
I can tell you what
this graph looks like.
An algorithm is really--
I don't know what
the outputs are.
these edges are.
But I want a fixed size
machine or procedure
that, if I give it an input,
it will generate an output.
And if it generates
an output, it better
be one of these correct outputs.
So if I have an algorithm
that takes in this input,
I really want it to
output this output,
or else it's not a
correct algorithm.
Similarly, for this one, it
could output any of these three
outputs, but if it outputs
this guy for this input,
that would not be a
correct algorithm.
And so generally, what we want
is an algorithm is a function.
It takes inputs to outputs.
An algorithm is some
kind of function
that takes these inputs,
maps it to a single output,
and that output better be
correct based on our problem.
So that's what our algorithm is.
It solves the
problem if it returns
a correct output for
every problem input
that is in our domain.
Does anyone have a
possible algorithm
for checking whether
any two of you
have the same birth time,
as specified before?
I'm going to let
someone else have a try.
Sure.
STUDENT: Just ask everyone
one by one, and every time
[INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Great-- so what
your colleague has said
is a great algorithm.
Essentially, what
it's going to do
is I'm going to put
you guys in some order,
I'm going to give
you each of you
a number, one through however
many number of students there
are in this class.
And I'm going to
interview you one by one.
I'm going to say,
what's your birthday?
And I'm going to write it down.
I'm going to put it in
some kind of record.
And then, as I keep
interviewing you,
I'm going to find
out your birthday.
I'm going to check the record.
I'm going to look through all
the birthdays in the record.
If I find a match,
then I return, yay--
I found a pair-- and I can stop.
Otherwise, if I get
through the record list,
I don't-- and I
don't find a match,
I just stick you at
the end of the record--
I add you to the
record, and then I
move on to the next person.
I keep doing this.
OK, so that's a
proposed algorithm
for this birthday problem.
For birthday problem,
what's the algorithm here?
Maintain a record.
Interview students
in some order.
And what does interviewing
a student mean?
It means two things.
It means check if
birthday in record.
And if it is, return a pair.
So return pair.
Otherwise, add a new
student to record.
And then, at the very end,
if I go through everybody
and I haven't found
a match yet, I'm
going to return
that there is none.
OK, so that's a statement
of an algorithm.
That's kind of the
level of description
that we'll be looking for you
in the three parts of this--
theory questions that we ask
you on your problem sets.
It's a verbal description
in words that--
it's maybe not enough for a
computer to know what to do,
but if you said this algorithm
to any of your friends
in this class, right they
would at least understand
what it is that you're doing.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Does an algorithm
have to be a pure function
in a mathematical sense?
JASON KU: Does an algorithm
have to be a pure function
in a mathematical sense?
As in it needs to map
to a single output?
STUDENT: As in it can't
modify some external state.
It can't take in state
and it can't do I/O.
JASON KU: So we're
talking about kind
of a functional programming
definition of a function.
I am talking about
the mathematical--
I have a binary
relation, and this thing
has an output for every
input, and there is exactly
one output to every input.
That's the mathematical
definition of function
that I'm using for when
I'm defining an algorithm.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Basically, is
an algorithm like a plan?
JASON KU: Yeah.
An algorithm's a
procedure that somehow--
I can do whatever
I want, but I have
to take one of these inputs and
I have to produce an output.
And at the end, it
better be correct.
So it's just a procedure.
You can think of it
as like a recipe.
It's just some
kind of procedure.
It's a sequence of things
that you should do,
and then, at the end, you
will return an output.
S here's a possible algorithm
for solving this birthday
problem.
Now, I've given you--
what I argue to you, or
I'm asserting to you,
is a solution to this
birthday problem.
And maybe you guys
agree with me,
and maybe some of you don't.
So how do I convince you
that this is correct?
If I was just running
this algorithm on, say,
the four students in
the front row here,
I could argue it
pretty well to you.
I could assign these
for people birthdays
in various combinations
of either their--
none of them have the same
birthday, some two of them
have the same birthday.
I could try all
possibilities, and I
could go through lots of
different possibilities
and I need to check that
this algorithm returns
the right answer
in all such cases.
But when I have--
I don't know--
300 of you, that's
going to be a little bit
more difficult to argue.
And so if I want to argue
something is correct in--
I want to prove something to you
for some large value, what kind
of technique do I use
to prove such things?
Yeah?
Induction, right?
And in general, what we do
in this class, what we do
is-- as a computer scientist is
we write a constant sized piece
of code that can take on any
arbitrarily large size input.
If the input can be arbitrarily
large, but our code is small,
then that code needs
to loop, or recurse,
or repeat some of
these lines of code
in order to just
read that output.
And so that's another way you
can arrive at this conclusion,
that we're going
to probably need
to use recursion, induction.
And that's part
of the reason why
we ask you to take
a course on proofs,
and inductive reasoning,
and discrete mathematics
before this class.
OK, so how do we prove
that this thing is correct?
We got to use induction.
So how can we set
up this induction?
What do I need for
an inductive proof?
Sure.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Base case--
we need a base case.
We need some kind
of a predicate.
Yeah, but we need
some kind of statement
of a hypothesis of something
that should be maintained.
And then we need to have an
inductive step, which basically
says I take a small
value of this thing,
I use the inductive
hypothesis, and I argue it
for a larger value of
my well-ordered set
that I'm inducting over.
For this algorithm,
if we're going
to try to prove correctness,
what I'm going to do
is I'm going to--
what do I want to
prove for this thing?
That, at the end of
interviewing all of you,
that my algorithm has
either already-- it
has returned with
a pair that match,
or if we're in a
case where there
wasn't a pair somewhere in my
set, that it returned none.
Right?
That would be correct.
So how can I
generalize that concept
to make it something
I can induct on?
What I'm going to do
is I'm going to say--
let's say, after I've
interviewed the first K
students, if there was a match
in those first K students,
I want to be sure that
I've returned a pair--
because if, after I
interview all of you,
I've maintained
that property, then
I'll be sure, at the
end of the process,
I will have returned
a pair, if one exists.
So here's going to be
my inductive hypothesis.
If first K students
contain a match,
algorithm returns a match
before interviewing, say,
student K plus 1.
So that's going to be
my inductive hypothesis.
Now, if there's n
students in this class,
and at the end of
my thing, I'm trying
to interview a student n plus
1-- oh, student n plus 1's
not there.
If I have maintained this,
then, if I replace K with n,
then I will have
returned a match
before interviewing
the last student--
when I have no
more students left.
And then this algorithm
returns none, as it should.
OK, so this inductive hypothesis
sets up a nice variable
to induct on.
This K I can have
increasing, up to n,
starting at some base case.
So what's my base case here?
My base case is--
the easiest thing I can do--
sure-- 2?
That's an easy thing I could do.
I could check those
possibilities,
but there's an even
easier base case.
Yeah?
There's an even easier
base case than 1.
STUDENT: 0--
JASON KU: 0, right?
After interviewing 0 students,
I haven't done any work, right?
Certainly, the first
0 can't have a match.
This inductive
hypothesis this is true
just because this initial
predicate is false.
So I can say, base case 0--
check.
Definitely, this
predicate holds for that.
OK.
Now we got to go for
the meat of this thing.
Assume the inductive
hypothesis true
for K equals, say, some K prime.
And we're considering
K prime plus 1.
Then we have two cases.
One of the nice
things about abduction
is that it isolates our problem
to not consider everything
all at once, but break it
down into a smaller interface
so I can do less
work at each step.
So there are two cases.
Either the first K
already had a match--
in which case, by our
inductive hypothesis,
we've already returned
a correct answer.
The other case is the--
it doesn't have a match, and
we interview the K plus 1th
student--
the K prime plus 1th student.
If there is a match in the
first K prime plus 1 students,
then it will include K plus--
the student K prime plus
1, because otherwise,
there would have been a match
in the things before it.
So there are two cases.
If K contains match, K prime.
If first K contains match--
already returned by induction.
Else, if K prime plus 1
student's contains match,
the algorithm checks all
of the possibilities--
K prime checks
against all students,
essentially by brute force.
It's a case analysis.
I check all of
the possibilities.
Check if birthday is in record--
I haven't told you
how to do that yet,
but if I'm able to
do that, I'm going
to check if it's in the record.
If it's in the record,
then there will be a match,
and I can return it.
Otherwise, I have-- re-establish
the inductive hypothesis
for the K prime plus 1 students.
Does that makes sense, guys?
Yeah.
OK, so that's how we
prove correctness.
This is a little bit
more formal than we
would ask you to do in
this class all the time,
but it's definitely sufficient
for the levels of arguments
that we will ask you to do.
The bar that we're
usually trying to set
is, if you communicated
to someone else taking
this class what
your algorithm was,
they would be able to code it
up and tell a stupid computer
how to do that thing.
Any questions on induction?
You're going to be using
it throughout this class,
and so if you are unfamiliar
with this line of argument,
then you should go
review some of that.
That would be good.
OK, so that's correctness,
being able to communicate
that the problem--
the algorithm we
stated was correct.
Now we want to argue
that it's efficient.
What does efficiency mean?
Efficiency just means
not only how fast
does this algorithm run,
but how fast does it
compare to other possible ways
of approaching this problem?
So how could we measure
how fast an algorithm runs?
This is kind of
a silly question.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Yeah.
Well, just record the time
it takes for a computer
to do this thing.
Now, there's a problem with
just coding up an algorithm,
telling a computer what to do,
and timing how long it takes.
Why?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: It would depend on
the size of your data set.
OK, we expect that, but
there's a bigger problem there.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: It depends on the
strength of your computer.
So I would expect that, if
I had a watch calculator
and I programmed
it to do something,
that might take a lot longer to
solve a problem than if I asked
IBM's research computer to
solve the same problem using
the same algorithm,
even with the same code,
because its underlying
operations are much faster.
How it runs is much faster.
So I don't want to
count how long it
would take on a real machine.
I want to abstract the
time it takes the machine
to do stuff out of the picture.
What I want to say
is, let's assume
that each kind of fundamental
operation that the computer can
do takes some fixed
amount of time.
How many of those kinds
of fixed operations
does the algorithm
need to perform to be
able to solve this problem?
So here we don't measure time.
Instead, count
fundamental operations.
OK?
We'll get to what some of
those fundamental operations
are in a second,
but the idea is we
want a measure of how well
an algorithm performs,
not necessarily
an implementation
of that algorithm--
kind of an abstract notion of
how well this algorithm does.
And so what we're going to use
to measure time or efficiency
is something called
asymptotic analysis.
Anyone here understand what
asymptotic analysis is?
Probably, since it's in both of
your prerequisites, I think--
but we will go through
a formal definition
of asymptotic notation
in recitation tomorrow,
and you'll get a lot of
practice in comparing functions
using an asymptotic analysis.
But just to give you
an idea, the idea
here is we don't measure time.
We instead measure ops.
And like your colleague
over here was saying before,
we expect performance--
I'm going to use performance,
instead of time here--
we expect that to depend
on size of our input.
If we're trying to
run an algorithm
to find a birthday
in this section,
we expect the algorithm to run
in a shorter amount of time
than if I were to run the
algorithm on all of you.
So we expect it to
perform differently,
depending on the
size of the input,
and how differently is
how we measure performance
relative to that input.
Usually we use n as a variable
for what the size of our input
is, but that's not
always the case.
So for example, if we have
an array that I give you--
an n-by-n array, that--
we're going to say n,
but what's the
size of our input?
How much information do
I need to convey to you
to give you that information?
It's n squared.
So that's the size of our
input in that context.
Or if I give you a graph, it's
usually the number of vertices
plus the number of edges.
That's how big--
how much space I
would need to convey to you
that graph, that information.
We compare how fast an
algorithm is with respect
to the size of the input.
We'll use the
asymptotic notation.
We have big O notation, which
corresponds to upper bounds.
We will have omega, which
corresponds to lower bounds.
And we have theta, which
corresponds to both.
This thing is tight.
It is bounded from
above and below
by a function of this form.
We have a couple
of common functions
that relate an
algorithm's input size
to its performance, some things
that we saw all the time.
Can anyone give
me some of those?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Say again.
JASON KU: Sorry.
Sorry.
I'm not asking
this question well,
but has anyone heard
of a linear algorithm--
a linear time algorithm?
That's basically saying that the
running time of my algorithm--
performance of my algorithm
is linear with respect
to the size of my input.
Right?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Say again.
STUDENT: Like putting
something in a list--
JASON KU: Like putting
OK.
There's a lot
behind that question
that we'll go into
later this week.
But that's an example of,
if I do it in a silly way,
I stick something in
the middle of a list
and I have to move everything.
That's an operation that
could take linear time.
So linear time is
a type of function.
We've got a number of these.
I'm going to start
with this one.
Does anyone know this one is?
Constant time-- basically, no
matter how I change the input,
the amount of time
this running time--
the performance of my
algorithm takes, it
doesn't really depend on that.
The next one up is
something like this.
This is logarithmic time.
We have data n, which
is linear, and log n.
Sometimes we call
this log linear,
but we usually just say n log n.
We have a quadratic
running time.
In general, if I have a
constant power up here,
it's n to the c
for some constant.
This is what we call
polynomial time,
as long as c is some constant.
And this right here is
what we mean by efficient,
in this class, usually.
In other classes, when
you have big data sets,
maybe this is efficient.
But in this class, generally
what we mean is polynomial.
And as you get down
this thing, things
are more and more efficient.
There's one class I'm going to
talk to you about over here,
which is something like--
let's do this-- 2 to the
theta of n, exponential time.
This is some constant to
a function of n that's,
let's say, super linear,
that's going to be pretty bad.
Why is it pretty bad?
If I were to plot some of these
things as a function of n--
let's say I plot values of up
to 1,000 on my n scale here.
What does constant look like?
Maybe this is 1,000 up here.
What does a constant look like?
Looks like a line--
it looks like a line
over here somewhere.
It could be as high as
I want, but eventually,
anything that's an
increasing function
will get bigger than this.
And on this scale,
if I use log base
2 or some reasonable
small constant,
what does log look like?
Well, let's do an easier one.
What does linear look like?
Yeah, this-- that's what I
saw what a lot of you doing.
That's linear.
That's the kind of base that
we're comparing everything
against.
What does log look like?
Like this-- OK,
but at this scale,
really, it's much closer
to constant than linear.
And actually, as n gets
much, much larger this almost
looks like a straight line.
It almost looks like a constant.
So log is almost just
as good as constant.
What does exponential look like?
It's the exact
inverse of this thing.
It's almost an exact
straight line going up.
So this is crap.
This is really good.
Almost anything in this region
over here is better right.
At least I'm gaining something.
I'm able to not go up too high
relative to my input size.
So quadratic-- I don't know--
is something like this,
and n log n is
something like this.
n log n, after a
long time, really
starts just looking linear
with a constant multiplied
in front of it.
OK, so these things
good, that thing bad--
OK?
That's what that's
trying to convey.
All right, so how do
we measure these things
if I don't know what my
fundamental operations are
that my computer can use?
So we need to define some
kind of model of computation
for what our computer is
allowed to do in constant time,
in a fixed amount of time.
In general, what we use
in this class is a machine
called a word RAM, which we use
for its theoretical brevity.
Word RAM is kind
of a loaded term.
What do these things mean?
Does someone know
what RAM means?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Random access memory--
it means that I can randomly
access different places
in memory in constant time.
That's the assumption
of random access memory.
Basically, what our
model of a computer is
you have memory,
which is essentially
just a string of bits.
It's just a bunch
of 1's and 0's.
And we have a computer, like
a CPU, which is really small.
It can basically hold a
small amount of information,
but it can change
that information.
It can operate on
that information,
and it also has instructions
to randomly access
different places in memory,
bring it into the CPU,
act on it, and read it back.
Does that makes sense?
But in general, we
don't have an address
for every bit in memory,
every 0 and 1 in memory.
Does anyone know how modern
computers are addressed?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: OK, so we're
going to get there.
Actually, what a modern
computer is addressed in
is bytes, collections of 8 bits.
So there's an address
I have for every 8 bits
in memory-- consecutive
8 bits in memory.
And so if I want to pull
something in into the CPU,
I give it an address.
It'll take some chunk, and bring
it into the CPU, operate on it,
and spit it back.
How big is that chunk?
This goes to the answer that
you were asking, which--
or saying, which is it's some
sequence of some fixed number
of bits, which we call a word.
A word is how big of
a chunk that the CPU
can take in from memory
at a time and operate on.
In your computers, how
big is that word size?
64 bits-- that's how much
I can operate on at a time.
When I was growing up,
when I was your age,
my word size was 32 bits.
And that actually was a
problem for my computer,
because in order for
me to be able to read
to address in
memory, I need to be
able to store that address
in my CPU, in a word.
But if I have 32 bits, how
many different addresses can
I address?
I have a limitation on the
memory addresses I can address,
right?
So how many different
memory addresses
can I address with 32 bits?
2 to the 32, right?
That makes sense.
Well, if you do that calculation
out, how big of a hard disk
can I have to access?
It's about 4 gigabytes.
So in my day, all
the hard drives
were limited to being
partitioned-- even if you
had a bigger than 4
gigabyte hard drive,
I had to partition it into
these 4 gigabyte chunks, which
the computer could
then read onto.
That was very
limiting, actually.
That's a restriction.
With 64 bits, what's
my limitation on memory
that I can address--
byte addressable?
Turns out to be something
like 20 exabytes--
to put this in
context, all data that
Google stores on
their servers, on all
drives throughout the world--
it's about 10.
So we're not going to run out
of this limitation very soon.
So what do we got
we've got a CPU.
It can address memory.
What are the operations
I can do in this CPU?
Generally, I have
binary operations.
I can compare to
words in memory,
and I can either do integer
arithmetic, logical operations,
bitwise operations--
but we're not going to use
those so much in this class.
And I can write and write
from an address in memory,
a word in constant time.
Those are the
operations that I have
available to me on most CPUs.
Some CPUs give you a
little bit more power,
but this is generally what we
analyze algorithms with respect
to.
OK?
But you'll notice
that my CPU is only
built to operate on a constant
amount of information at once--
generally, two words in memory.
An operation produces a
third one, and I spit it out.
It takes a constant
amount of time
to operate on a constant
amount of memory.
If I want to operate on a
linear amount of memory--
n things-- how long
is that going to take?
If I just want to read
everything in that thing,
it's going to take
me linear time,
because I have to read
every part of that thing.
OK, so in general,
what we're going
to do for the first half
of this class mostly--
first eight lectures, anyway--
is talk about data structures.
And it's going to be
concerned about not operating
on constant amount of data at
a time, like our CPU is doing,
but instead, what it's
going to do is operate on--
store a large amount of data
and support different operations
on that data.
So if I had a record
that I want to maintain
to store those birthdays
that we had before,
I might use something
like a static array, which
you guys maybe are not
familiar with, if you
have been working in Python is
your only programming language.
Python has a lot of really
interesting data structures,
like a list, and a
set, and a dictionary,
and all these kinds
of things that
are actually not in this model.
There's actually a lot of code
between you and the computer,
and it's not always
clear how much time
that interface is taking.
And so what we're going
to do starting on Thursday
is talk about ways of
storing a non-constant amount
of information to
make operations
on that information faster.
So just before you go,
I just want to give you
a quick overview of the class.
To solve an algorithms
class-- an algorithm
problem in this
class, we essentially
have two different strategies.
We can either reduced to using
the solution to a problem we
know how to solve,
or we can design
our own algorithm,
which is going
to be recursive in nature.
We're going to either put
stuff in the data structure
and solve a sorting problem,
or search in a graph.
And then, to design a
recursive algorithm,
we have various
design paradigms.
This is all in your notes,
but this is essentially
the structure of the class.
We're going to spend quiz 1,
the first eight lectures on data
structures and sorting.
Second quiz will be on shortest
paths, algorithms, and graphs,
and then the last one will
be on dynamic programming.
OK, that's the end
of the first lecture.
Thanks for coming.